CHAO-HUI JENNY LIU: There was a performance
of "Farewell My Concubine" at Princeton.
And to our surprise tickets
sold out in 4 days.
[CAO JIN: Speaking Chinese]
CHAO-HUI JENNY LIU: We're landing 19
American students here in Shanghai
and dropping them into
immersion Peking opera.
We have the actors working closely
with our students in very small groups.
Each of the students learn an aria by the
traditional way of teaching line-by-line
and the teacher explaining, as they go along,
what it means and then expanding on it.
That's part of the tradition
and that's part of the culture.
TERESA IRIGOYEN-LOPEZ: I had actually seen
this company perform at Princeton last fall.
I really had no clue what it meant to
come here like what classes would be like.
It changes a lot my idea
of what art means.
Like what different disciplines mean and also,
like, specifically, like, what dance means.
Because for me, dance was always
like a lot of movement and here
like even the tiniest movement is dance because
it's already combined with, your face means
so much more when you're
dancing really slowly.
And your eyes mean so much more when like
that is all that constitutes the dance.
MING WILSON: My first memory of Peking
opera was when I was 3 and I remember
on TV seeing someone dressed as a
woman with the very colorful makeup.
Yesterday was actually
a great moment for me
because I actually started
feeling my nasal cavity vibrating.
Probably, to a normal person it's weird,
but to me it was like, wow this is --
now I'm actually getting something
very close to Peking opera style.
SHERYL CHOW: In Western opera, they focus on
singing but in Peking opera those gestures,
those dance, those movements
are integrated with the singing.
So they are all together. While
you are singing you have
to remember [singing]. The
excerpt that I am working on
it's a love story about
a lady in the morning.
She go out and then feed the chicken
and go back to do the needle work.
WILLIAM SIMON: What Peking Opera tries
to do, like a lot of other art forms,
is just tell a story really
well in its particular way.
WENDY HELLER: It opens up the students'
ears to imagine that this one aesthetic
of what is beautiful does not necessarily
pertain within another culture.
And that's an extraordinarily rich kind of
experience to have both aurally and physically.
SHERYL CHOW: After three weeks of practice and then
getting onto the stage and perform the piece --
it's a really great
sense of accomplishment.
WILLIAM SIMON: We want to make our teacher proud
so we are a little nervous because of that.
But, I think it went well.
TERESA IRIGOYEN-LOPEZ: To see, like, such an
important Peking opera company invite us here,
teach us what they've been learning from so
many years, let us perform with other students
and see how they actually enjoy our
performance which is really nice.
[CAO JIN: Speaking Chinese]
[MUSIC]